foreign
this morning's Health watch we are
looking at an unusual therapy for
Parkinson's Disease the neurological
disorder affects one in every hundred
people age 60 and older it's more common
in men than women symptoms include
Tremors muscle stiffness slow movement
and problems with balance and
coordination Meg Oliver shows us how a
beloved game can help both Body and Soul
three years ago Robin Seltzer was
diagnosed with Parkinson's disease the
once athletic 67 year old symptoms were
so bad he could barely get out of bed I
kind of was in the middle of covid I
couldn't get access to a doctor so how
bad did it get I lost 70 pounds
I was flapping
along with physical therapy and
medication to manage symptoms like
Tremors stiffness and slowness Dr Alana
Clark at Hackensack University Medical
Center offered a surprising option
when your doctor first said you should
do ping pong what was your reaction but
actually
how could that help anybody ping pong
has clearly been shown to have a
positive impact on their progression of
the disease and in a way that the
medication alone is not doing Dr Clara
neuropsychologist Elizabeth Cara
co-founded the New Jersey chapter of
ping pong Parkinson a non-profit with
more than 200 chapters in 26 countries
including an international competition
how does ping pong help a Parkinson's
patient areas involved in motor planning
also have ties to other areas of the
brain that impact those cognitive skills
that we see impacted in Parkinson's
disease things like the planning the
problem solving and so when we're
playing ping pong we know that those
areas of the brain end up being
activated
while all forms of exercise are
beneficial the thing that makes ping
pong unique is that it incorporates a
focus on balance hand-eye coordination
and the Rhythm or Pace of reciprocal
play so it really hits the trifecta of
physical cognitive and social activities
every Tuesday night in River Edge New
Jersey Parkinson's patients or hungers
as they're called play with volunteers
of all ages called hitters there's a
tendency if your parking zoning to stand
like this right and this forces you to
move to move right yeah you're forcing
me to move
oh she's a ringer when I start up I'm a
little stiff my shots are a little bit
off my timing's a little bit off and I'm
a little bit frustrated and then after
about 15 or 20 minutes suddenly things
kick in how long does that last in terms
of feeling a little bit looser and more
relaxed I'd say last at least a couple
of days
the goal is to improve attention
movement mood and social connection
among people striving to outpace a
progressive disease how has it changed
your outlook on the future it's kind of
opened me up to new experiences like
I've thought over the last few weeks
maybe I could get back on skis you know
even if it's just going down the bunny
slope I really miss that this is opening
doors it is yes it is it's opening doors
and it provides a certain amount of
imagination
opening doors and mines Robin told me he
finds ping pong so intoxicating he is
training for next year's World
Championships yes that is the thing when
you look at how much his physical
condition has improved in the eight
months he's been playing you can bet
he's probably going to be there it's in
Greece next November beautiful what I
loved about the pieces Robin said that
one session gave him positive impacts
lasting several days I know I was
surprised at that too and he's like a
little kid all of them when they came in
and we were shooting they were like move
away we're ready to play yeah
yeah very impressive stuff but speaking
of impressive and speaking of ready to
play
um you got some skills Nate yeah that
runs in the office did you get
competitive a little bit just a tap
photographer was a little annoyed with
me you have a ping pong table in the
basement or something oh yeah growing up
all of our traditions
you got to get one here in the studio
yeah oh that would be perfect yeah Meg
thank you so much